well joining me now is the snp's leader
in Westminster Stephen Flynn hi nice to
see you Stephen
um what did you think of of the debate
one of my colleagues John Craig said
that he felt that Hamza Yusuf who you
are supporting was guilty of a bit of
mansplaining well I've not seen the
beating his entirety I'll be honest with
you I was Voting last night against the
government's deplorable way Asylum seek
or Bill but what I have seen on Twitter
uh when I got back to the flat last
night and what I've seen this morning
it's been very similar to the the
previous debates I think there's been
robust exchanges to say the least uh and
I'll uh I'm looking forward to the end
of the contest that's probably the the
best way to put it because I think it's
time that the the SNP moved on that we
focused on delivering we focused on the
big issues that are facing the people of
Scotland the cost of living crisis and
the challenges which exist within our
Health Service and Health Services
across the UK and of course how we get
to that independent future
yourself the right person to do that
though we've put carried out a lot of
polls in advance of the debate last
night
um one about Ham's use of himself twice
as many people think that he'd be a bad
first Minister as a good one let's have
a quick look at the the results of that
poll
um
can we bring it up
oh there we are uh who would be a bad
leader of the country uh 44 Hamza you
saw 39 Ash Regan 36 Kate Forbes it seems
that the public maybe don't agree with
you but no I think comes will be uh
fantastic and the reason for that is
simple you know life is tough at the
moment and people are crying out for a
little bit of Hope we've had brexit
we've had the pandemic we've had Liz
truss destroying the the economy and of
course we've got the cost of living
crisis and humza's plans in respect of
chayokia in Scotland are transformative
expanding it to one and two year olds
which is a win-win for families and also
for the economy he wants to create that
green Industrial Revolution that I'm
very keen to see being in the north east
of Scotland I want to see that just
transition that protects jobs and the
climate but perhaps most important of
all I think you'll bring the Scottish
national party back together he will he
will unite us and lead us to hopefully
bigger and better things you've not
mentioned Independence yet which
surprised me I I think I I did
an answer and because that that's
obviously the the thing which which
defines the Scottish national party
um is the ultimate goal that we want to
to achieve but we've also got to be
cognizant of the challenges that are
facing people on a day-to-day basis at
the moment you know we've got the
Chancellor's budget
um in tomorrow actually and we've not
heard from him yet what his plans are in
relation to energy bills that's the big
thing that people are contacting me
about they want to know how they're
going to get by on a monthly basis
they're getting squeezed whichever way
they turn whether they go to the shops
for their food costs whether it's their
mortgage costs or their or their um or
or indeed
um their energy bills they're getting
challenged everywhere they turn we need
the UK government to take action we've
proposed that they don't just freeze
bills that they cut them by 500 pounds a
year because they have the fiscal
Headroom to do that that's that's the
big issues of the day we should be
focusing on that and I think it's
incumbent of all upon all of us to be
talking about the things that matter to
people in Scotland but the latest polls
again don't show that there is an
overwhelming majority backing
Independence in Scotland
um one that we we carried a Hugo Paul
Sky and use 46 percent backing an exit
from the UK compared to 54 who want to
stay it doesn't seem that it is the
right time to be raising this again well
the pause for the last couple of years
have generally been there thereabouts 50
50 this way from us being 50 feet well
46 54. that's a big difference isn't it
yeah but there's sway from us being on
54 to the north side being on 54 and
that's happened
um consecutively uh and on many
occasions over the course of the of the
last couple of years but that's where
it's incumbent upon us to have a leader
who addresses the big issues that are
facing people at the moment but also
builds that that widespread support
across Society in Scotland for that
better fairer Greener independent future
that we we want to see and I think our
views and values in Scotland are in
stark contrast to those those at
Westminster we have a conservative party
which is going down a track which
frankly I don't think any of us quite
seen coming the right one politics are
emanating from the chancellor and the
the Prime Minister and the Home
Secretary and of course you have a labor
party which is just as Keen as the
Tories are when it comes to the the
removal of the the UK from the European
Union who don't seem to think the single
Market uh Customs union and freedom
movement is a good thing I want to deny
the people of Scotland their Democratic
right to choose no matter which way
people of Scotland turn you have a
different shade of blue uh Westminster
that's not the future we want we want a
better brighter future for everyone in
Scotland but but some would say that
that um Yusuf has in a sense the same
shade of blue for the SNP in Scotland is
just the continuity candidate Nicholas
sturgeon 2.0 I I don't necessarily buy
into this continuity aspect I think each
and every politician is their own person
and ultimately what we're going to have
is change I think change is a good thing
I think change affords us the
opportunity to have a little bit of Hope
back in our politics as well but when it
comes to the smp's record of delivery in
government it's something that we should
be proud of as something that we we
should celebrate we've delivered a lot
for the people of Scotland over the
course of our tenure in government and
even if you look at some of the
portfolios that Hamza has held when it
came to transport the Queensbury costs
and a huge infrastructure project which
came in uh under budget and and on time
when he was just the secretary he came
was at a record laws and of course when
he's Health secretary as he is now
despite the challenges that we all face
in our health services across the UK
um the Health Service in Scotland is
performing the best of all those and
we've not had a single nurses stake on
homes as watch so I think he has a
record that's right but there's real
problems with funding isn't there NHS
Azure and Aaron says it needs 13 million
to hit its reduced wasting time it's
getting seven point a and it's just
highly needs 12.5 million it's getting
8.3 you know you can go through all of
them they're not getting the money they
need to put it another way it would
require Savings of around 621 million
for these trusts to break even there is
an issue with Healthcare in Scotland and
that's down to the SMP there is an issue
when it comes to finance but of course
the leaf of power when it comes to
financing these aisles are determined
not in Hollywood determined that
Westminster the Scottish government
operates with a fixed budget which is
given to them each and every year now
there is some tax varying Powers within
that but not to the extent that would be
able to fill the the black hole the
Westminster austerity has has of course
created but the the point that was
making there was that the Scottish
Health Services performing better
despite the challenges we face and there
are significant challenges better than
all other health services on these
aisles it depends which metrics those
are the important ones because that's
people getting treated which is the most
important thing and and also the um
there's not been a single nurses strike
I think those are things to be
celebrated and they've happened on on
hamza's watch Stephen Flynn a good talk
to you thanks a lot for coming in thank
you